this story is insane and actually true
retail Traders are hooked into GameStop
look at this chart I think they think
it's a good investment the money man
happy to take it somebody is how
Financial people describe the rest of us
Wall Street is betting that this company
is going to fail and if it fails these
hedge fund people make a ton of money
because of social media these people
found a way to boost the value of the
company and disrupt this convoluted
system GameStop's going nuts another
record high
it's David versus Goliath how much did
we make today 5 million how much did we
lose today a billion and yesterday four
million and yesterday a billion we're
like really rich no one wants to lose
hundreds of millions of dollars isn't
that rich dudes freaking out right now
it's like yeah we're the dumb money and
we're coming for you the word on the
street is they're drowning oh that's
crazy we're doing great
exclusively in movie theaters rated R